y amplia victoria de la derecha en las
urnas el partido popular se hizo con 65
escaños de la asamblea de la comunidad
de madrid' reunió el doble de los votos
obtenidos en las elecciones de 2019 y
quedó a pocos asientos de la mayoría
absoluta lo que le da la victoria a la
actual presidenta de la comunidad isabel
díaz ayuso a gracias por haber hecho
historia hoy empieza de nuevo un nuevo
capítulo en la historia de españa porque
hoy desde madrid desde el kilómetro cero
vamos a recuperar el orgullo el
sentimiento de pertenencia la cultura
del esfuerzo y por encima de todo la
convivencia la unidad y la libertad que
necesita españa durante meses días hay
uso de soy yo los mandatos del gobierno
central sobre la pandemia y mantuvo
abiertos los bares restaurantes y
comercios no esenciales con el lema
libertad atrajo a varios madrileños
cansados de las restricciones sanitarias
la izquierda por su parte quedó
profundamente herida el partido
socialista español pasó de 37 a 24
asientos y sus socios de unidad podemos
tan sólo consiguieron 10 lo que los deja
muy
el poder tras conocerse los resultados
el histórico líder de podemos el icono
de la izquierda pablo iglesias anunció
su retiro de la política dejó todos mis
cargos dejó la política entendida como
política de partido entendida como
política institucional seguiré
comprometido con mi país pero yo no voy
a hacer un tapón para una renovación de
liderazgos que se tiene que producir en
nuestra fuerza política ahora se espera
que díaz ayuso intente formar gobierno
con el apoyo de los ultraderechistas de
box quienes pasaron de 12 a 3 escaños
la formación ultra conservadora ya ha
manifestado su voluntad de formar
coalición